los combates continúan en Ucrania
especialmente en torno a buhmud en la
región oriental de doñaki calificada de
fortaleza por el presidente Ucrania
nuevo bolodiar zelanski los meses de
Sangrienta batalla han devastado la
ciudad y sus alrededores
Hola hemos venido a evacuarte
por qué te quedaste aquí
porque me amputaron la pierna dos Trozos
de metralla me alcanzaron por debajo de
la rodilla
antes de la guerra unas 75.000 personas
vivían en bahamut con los 7.000
habitantes que cuenta ahora la ciudad ha
perdido el 90% de su población pero
ciertos residentes se mantienen firmes
en quedarse
he vivido aquí Toda mi vida más que
nadie no puedo abandonar esta ciudad de
lo contrario se derrumbará mientras
moscurre y vindica nuevos avances en la
región de doniaski quien celebra el
último paquete ayuda militar que Estados
Unidos proporcionara Ucrania más de dos
mil millones de dólares incluyendo
municiones y cohetes de largo alcance
desde el inicio de la guerra Estados
Unidos ha destinado cerca de 30 mil
millones de dólares en ayuda militar a
kiev lo que le convierte en el país que
más ha ayudado a Ucrania hasta ahora